nevada casinos pulled in a record 13.4
billion dollars in gambling revenue in
2021 according to the nevada gaming
control board the total gaming jackpot
last year also beat pre-pandemic numbers
in 2019 by 11.6 percent the last
all-time high was in 2007 when the state
reported 12.8 billion dollars in gaming
revenue experts attribute the increase
to the rollout of the coveted vaccines
which eliminated restrictions on
gambling floors once restrictions lifted
pent up demand for gambling propelled
nevada on a record 10-month streak of
more than 1 billion dollars in monthly
revenue slot machines remained nevada's
cash cow in 2021 the state collected 9.2
billion dollars last year from slots an
all-time record for the state and a more
than 16 percent increase over 2019
nevada sportsbooks collected 8.1 billion
dollars in wagers and won
445.1 million dollars during 2021 both
all-time records
but gambling stocks haven't been as
lucky research firm macquarie downgraded
regional casino company red rock resorts
which is majority owned by the
billionaire brothers frank and lorenzo
fertitta from outperform to neutral wind
saw its stock price dipped 24 over the
last year due to concerns over macau's
licensing process and four percent this
week after news broke that's looking to
sell its mobile betting outfit win bet
for a steep discount
[Music]
you